i want to i want to now get into sort of
the um
what's the right word irreverence of the
psychosis here we have this story
i don't i don't know what this is sis
mocked actress oh actress is mocking
jesus proofreader yeah headline for
uploading a video of herself reading a
self-penned poem saying she wishes she'd
been putin's mom
so she could have hugged him to stop him
turning into a warmonger actress anna
lynn mccord 34 posted a bizarre poem
online thursday about her desire to be
putin's mother
putin 69 ordered a full-scale invasion
of ukraine okay now yeah do they have
this
let's play it because it good oh wait i
got to turn this down on don't i yeah
okay we got this it's going to be you
guys ready for this one yeah
it's still muted okay here we
go dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
that was when i paused at the first one
oh come on
stupid things not working i was like
this is cringe it's really quiet anyway
cringe all right is it gonna work
never with the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky all right we're not gonna
listen to this oh my god the problem i
have with that is it wasn't genuine she
wasn't saying it she was just reading a
pill
with like cadence to it it didn't sound
like she actually meant it
that was like i was gonna say like
that's unbearably critical oh my gosh
something is we we have a malignancy in
in this in this country
of vapid shells of people
who do things like this
where they're like i don't know about
ukraine i don't care about russia i
heard the name putin in the news
let me make a video you know what social
media was a mistake yep there are just
some people that shouldn't be allowed to
post yep i am kidding this is a joke
they should be censored all right
maybe miners shouldn't be able to post i
don't know
she's 34 ian she should know you look at
this she's half the age you look at this
and it's oh my gosh
it's so absurd you don't even know what
what to start with it's
who is this
hollywood actress and what does she have
to do or what does she know about
90210 man come on don't you know and
what does this poem help i mean this is
this is typical like america like the
toxic american culture where we think
like you know if enough hearts bleed and
we you know and we shed enough tears and
hashtag hard enough like we're going to
solve world problems like like this is
going to come across vladimir putin's
desk
and
a tear is going to like yeah
just a single tier is going to just drop
from his like stone stature and and you
know what he's going to say
let's pull back he's going to slam the
table
she was right and i too wish you were my
mother
i think this this reminds me of um
there's this like kind of idea like oh
if i go back and help hitler when he was
a baby and like give him the kindness he
needed to become an artist maybe you
wouldn't have become a psych
psychoactive psychoactive psychological
dictator but uh i think that's this idea
that he didn't do drugs though yeah he
was all on amphetamines and that stopped
he was just shell shocked from world war
one destroyed mind
this girl i think is doing that with
putin she's like oh if i could have if
somehow i could have reached his inner
child then maybe he wouldn't be so vile
no i'm very cynical about it have you
guys ever heard this lady's name before
in your life no no no no ian no this
person never heard of this lady no yeah
i haven't either until today hey look
she's getting it said she was on 90210
so i guess that makes her somewhat
credible yeah i mean she's got like two
hundred thousand followers
i would imagine right the 900 reboot
yeah
i know the original i was your mother
you would have been so loved
oh man
they're trying
this is like this is uh this is american
you know uh toxic culture trying or
hollywood culture trying to tie this to
like toxic masculinity in some way we're
a silly people dude
and again look at our priorities we're
like putin like you know if you just had
a mother it would be okay it's like
let's not talk about like look at any of
the other he's got actors in this
his mom's like
look at this off my back
look at look at hold on hold on there's
a picture they say although mccord
blames the family matriarch putin's
mother maria
shalamova has been characterized by
others as a kind factory worker who
secretly baptized him
could you imagine you know if anything
it's going to happen putin's going to be
like what'd you say about my mom
yeah i could get i understand wanting to
emotionally connect with vladimir putin
right now and you have the technology to
do it so you may as well try but don't
read a script man there's a poem that
you wrote that you're
come on do it genuinely if you're gonna
do it otherwise you're just you're just
burning the ground you walk on it's just
there's so much insanity this is this
isn't the only insane thing there's this
this post from a lady and she's like
the only reason that putin's allowed to
wage war is because he's white i was
just trying to find that as we were
reading this other headline if a black
or brown man had invaded ukraine it
would have been swiftly dealt with and
it's like it would have been a loud they
said it would have it wouldn't have been
allowed
like none of this is allowed and again
that goes to the it just goes to
highlight how little these people
actually understand
the the gravity and the severity of the
situation that is unfolding right before
our eyes these people vote
that's scary it is it's very scary you
know and i think it was thomas edison
that said that said the greatest that's
the the you know the greatest threat to
a democracy is an uneducated public and
we are looking at
millions of them at this point yep oh
man zombie hordes
you know who people who vote with their
emotions you know i'm i'm quite certain
that this woman went out and and
probably voted against trump because she
thought his tweets were mean yep that's
exactly it this that's a good point this
story of this woman saying if i was your
mother you had been so held it shows the
stupidity the ignorance
and and i would i would bet a large sum
of money she voted joe biden oh for sure
yeah i would i would
i would absolutely bet that
i i cannot imagine i mean who knows
maybe she she voted for trump i really
doubt it it's crazy you know you see
these people and they say things like
well it's a good thing trump's not
president and i'm like is it but it's
bad like the bad thing happened
like it didn't all of that all of the
things that you said were going to
happen under trump are happening right
now yep the bad things didn't happen
under trump exactly it's all happening
now
it's remarkable that they're like well
if if trump was president everything
would be a whole lot worse and it's like
but it wasn't you had him as president
the economy was great putin didn't
invade ukraine biden gets in and then he
does within a year
and you think the issue is putin would
have done it anyway
and it would have been worse with trump
all right man
some people are just lost no i don't
think you can even start to reason with
that because that's
that's that
they have they have already made up
their mind and and any anything you
throw is going to lead them back to
their original conclusion no matter what
yeah
and it's it comes from just a genuine
lack of understanding i think to the
severity of the situation and and lydia
what you were saying earlier about how
the um
the the less people understood where
ukraine was the more the more they
wanted intervention i guarantee that if
you put a globe in front of this this
young lady here that she will not be
able to define ukraine yeah at all
absolutely probably five guesses and she
probably still would not be able to get
it you could play wordle with her and
say guess the letters and she still
would be like
what's
up crying
it's like it's pronounced ukraine
i thought it was u-c-r-a-n-e
close but not quite
this is why i'm talking about just
buying all those coconuts and sitting
back and just machete
machete them open and see that straw in
there and just sit back i remember the
good old days i went to rio once
dollar it's like a buck for a coconut
yeah everywhere you sit on the beach you
walk right out of your hotel and you sit
on the beach and you just get a coke
right on copacabana right there have you
ever been yes oh it's amazing i went
during carnival yes and they got snacks
and food we got street food yeah and
meat on a stick right in the street
right yep yeah it's good living see
that's what i'm thinking about
well uh i do have a brazilian visa there
you go i'm just thinking you know as it
all comes crumbling down maybe maybe we
should spend time with our loved ones
and smile and uh it's like have you seen
the movie don't look up
at the end when they're all at the table
holding hands and it's like the world's
about to end i'm like that's kind of how
i feel right now i know i i feel very i
made a video last night that i didn't
end up uploading because it was so it
got so dark like i
i i want to believe that
we're better than animals but we're just
animals someone so someone super chatted
she was trying to kill putin by getting
him to die laughing
could you imagine if like
this story comes out that putin had a
stroke
and then like
there's a photo of him on the ground
confirming it and on his phone is a
picture of the woman and a big smile on
his face
and then someone's like i think he
laughed himself into a stroke and died i
think this woman wore his over i think
this woman stopped world war three
she actually did it the mad woman all it
took was one poem yep thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there
you